foreign
how do you think about rules like was
missing Google the result of a flaw in
the set of rules that you had at the
time or was it just sort of a a
collateral
Miss let me work my way back to it
because it's clearly the biggest mistake
of my career so I it's something I
thought about a lot
yeah so I think any investor starts with
just building bedrock and that comes
from reading and there's a ton of books
in history you can read you can go
through you know all the Buffett letters
as an example you know you can read
Peter Lynch's one up on Wall Street
there's my good friend Mike mobison has
put out some amazing books that are a
lot more nuanced about stock prices that
kind of thing a random walk down Wall
Street by Burton McHale and and then you
build your bedrock and then you know
you're out there and you're looking for
an opportunity so I think public stocks
are a little different than Venture but
there's some overlap but you're looking
for you know a reality that you think is
going to emerge that's not priced into
the stock so that requires you both to
know or to think you know where the
world's going and also to know what the
expectations are currently embedded in
the stock because if you just have the
same opinion it's already embedded
you're not going to make any money
there's a great piece by Howard marks
where he talks about you have to be act
you have to be right and contrarian you
know you can't just be right you have to
be right and contrarian and that's more
difficult there's a famous saying that
I'm sure has been uttered on your
podcast before the kind of strong
opinions Lucy held and yes I think I
think all investors have to work within
that framework because things change
there's many many variables
none of them are constant they're all
Dynamic and the minute you set a very
hard rule then you might be setting
yourself up for a mistake
and Venture I have found is a world
where that happens frequently and so the
Google example you know and it's really
important to say that we didn't lay
Chase like they presented there were 25
employees layering Sergey presented they
presented to I'm sure a whole bunch of
firms and we didn't lay Chase we should
have played Chase but we didn't you know
at the time
Yahoo was at ten dollars down from like
80 excite was going bankrupt so search
didn't look that exciting from an
external viewpoint
you had two PhD Founders who had never
been a CEO before and were insistent
they were going to be good as a CEO
normally that's a red flag you know two
PhD founders
and there was there was just a number of
things where you would make a list and
say oops you know this probably isn't
isn't what you want to do now I'd like
to highlight and I always do the two
best Venture capitalists in the world at
the time John door Mike Moritz
kind of locked hands and said yes right
and so it'd be it'd be erroneous for me
to say like oh if you were you know a
well-studied venture capitalist you
obviously get to know at that point in
time because the two best didn't and and
I think it's just the subtlety of the
game
there's a there's a great reality
Adventure that a lot of people talk
about now but you can only lose one time
your money and yeah in a case like
Google you make what ten thousand times
your money and that asymmetric result
means you have to bias towards positive
in a situation like that because the
odds are just ridiculously different
yeah and so what should have happened is
I remember one of my partners looking at
Larry and saying what does it take to
get this deal done right now because he
was a closer he was a closer type and
Larry said 120 pre and we should have
said how about 150 like if I could go
back
if I could go back but you can't go back
deal got done at like 80. so below what
Larry had had told us but still
obviously historic so how did you then
revise your rules of thumb or rules
moving forward after that if it all like
is a case like that granted it turned
into what Google is now
so it's easy to maybe punish yourself
for not not laying Chase but how did
things change after that you know after
that like the firm did Twitter Snapchat
Uber
you know we got some right you know
after yeah yeah and around that time I
remember we used to give a book out to
our LPS our limited partners our
investors at every annual meeting and I
think Bruce had just read the rational
Optimist which is a Matt Ridley book and
he started using a phrase at our partner
meaning what could go right
and because of this asymmetric outcome
thing where you could make ten thousand
times your money and only lose once on
the downside it was the right frame of
mind so like
it's very easy to get into a trap
Adventure where getting no right feels
like a win and it's just not yet I mean
obviously you can't do every deal you
know you can't do every investment you
go broke but like getting overly jazzed
about correctly you know
identifying a negative or a no like it's
just not that big a deal it's not the
job the job is to find the outliers